So I'm thinking about Sally Ride again. On June 18th 1983 she became the first
American woman to enter a low earth orbit. I'd like to sort of mentally
recreate that day, so let's start with something relatively simple that we can
do. What day of the week was that? I'm going to assign numbers to the days of
the week. So Sunday it'll be 0, Monday will be 1, Tuesday 2, and so on. Write a
program that takes a date and tells you what day of the week that was. You'll
need a reference day to start with, so I'll tell you that January 1st, 1900,
was a Monday. You'll want to write a program that uses this fact to count the
right number of days To get to the right day of the week. You can use the fact
that January 1st, 1900 was a Monday in your program.